[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance there is strong reason to
believe that there is a grand jury
sitting in the Eastern District of
Virginia right now hearing evidence
about the connections between Donald
Trump's presidential campaign and the
Russians and there is likewise reason to
believe that a grand jury possibly the
same one in Virginia has already issued
warrants in connection with Trump and
Russia and there are now new indications
suggesting that the FBI may have
targeted as many as forty two
individuals in the Trump Russia case and
most importantly much of this appears to
have been at minimum quite likely
confirmed when the FBI director James
Comey testified before the Senate
Judiciary Committee this started with a
tweet from April 28th from a former
Clinton White House staffer named Claude
Taylor quote this just in from a source
with knowledge of commis investigation
to grand juries have convened and I know
that one is almost complete
Republican advertising man and former
Giuliani staffer Rick Wilson retweeted
Taylor adding just one word quote same
and then James Comey testified and three
hours into that testimony as the eyes of
reporters and Senators alike began to
glaze over
Comey said it at 1:42 Eastern Daylight
Time on Wednesday May 3rd he was asked a
question by Senator mazie Hirono of
Hawaii so in the investigations that
you're currently doing on the Russian
interference and the Trump teams
relationship are you coordinating with
any US Attorney's Office yes
investigations two sets of prosecutors
main justice the National Security
Division and the Eastern District of
Virginia US Attorney's Office Comey
matter-of-factly confirmed that the FBI
was to use senator Hirono x' term
coordinating with to quote again what we
just heard him say two sets of
prosecutors the main justice the
National Security Division and the
Eastern District of Virginia US
Attorney's Office I asked the smartest
man I know John Dean Nixon's White House
Counsel and the survivor of presidential
scandals past to translate what
coordinating could mean to the director
of the FBI coordinating with the
National Security Division of just
Department headquarters could mean
almost anything but coordinating with
the office of the US attorney in the
Eastern District of Virginia John Dean
says commis testimony makes it difficult
to believe that there is not a grand
jury in the Eastern District of Virginia
a grand jury would obviously be one
reason the FBI would be coordinating
with the US attorney there right after
Comey added credence to Taylor's tweet
from April 28th Taylor acting as a kind
of citizen journalist took this whole
thing to get another higher level I now
have two sources within legal community
confirming that a DC area judge has
signed two warrants related to commis
trump investigation warrants search
warrants or arrest warrants taylor's
sources are not certain they believe
there are at least two sealed warrants
those sources are also pointing to the
fact that the reported grand jury in the
Eastern District of Virginia would be
under the jurisdiction of the US
Attorney for that region dana buente
until last month dana buente was the
Acting Deputy Attorney General of the
United States after the firing of Sally
Yates but Taylor's sources now add that
for months
beau wente has maintained a strict
quarantine against any contact with the
Attorney General mr. sessions mr.
sessions has recused himself from the
Trump Russia story because sessions was
not honest during his confirmation
hearing about his own contact with the
Russians Taylor's sources say in short
that on the subjects of general Flynn
and Trump and Russia buente no longer
reports to attorney General Sessions and
is essentially operating independently
and Taylor's sources also report that
the target list in the FBI investigation
of Trump and Russia ranges between 28
and 42 different individuals in any
event what Taylor has apparently
unearthed what Comey has said what other
independent investigators like Louie's
bench and John Schindler and Rick Wilson
and many others have alleged is if it is
corroborated so far ahead of the
so-called professional journalists that
it almost cannot be quantified Taylor
even seems to have a handle on the
nature of the cases to grand juries to
cases he tweeted one is a RICO case Rico
- tearing the other is a Farah foreign
agents Registration Act case the Farah
case loops in the Russians in Trump
Tower is larger and also does involve
Rico the other unrelated RICO case
involves no election matters it involves
money laundering as a predicate offense
so in short man named Claude Taylor
tweets there are two Trump Russia grand
juries five days later James Comey says
his FBI is coordinating with the US
Attorney's Office for the Eastern
District of Virginia on Trump and Russia
FBI coordination with the US Attorney's
Office could very well mean getting
evidence and testimony seen and heard by
a grand jury no hyperbole is needed here
a federal grand jury perhaps more than
one of them quite likely actively
investigating right now what links
existed between Trump's presidential
campaign and the Russians the FBI in its
directors own words coordinating with
the office of the US attorney in whose
district that grand jury apparently sits
and from Claude Taylor's sources the FBI
target list on Trump and Russia
reportedly includes at least 28 names
and as many as 42 names these are the
most important events in the
investigation of Trump and Russia since
the day of the presidential election
resist peace